j'adore chanter et danser salut tout le
monde
[Musique]
pour ça que de celles jeter 6 la baston
compris ça me donne presque envie
d'avoir une graine de faire sucer quand
je pense à toi oui vous êtes les deux
agents les plus décorés du service ce
serait quoi
dirais que c'est un vol qui a mal tourné
moi c'était pas un bol c'est un meurtre
quelqu'un qui élimine des marionnettes
et des plateaux content je suis une
femme ça fait rien marqué c'est encore
mais on peut faire du cisr on va
attraper les trous de cul qui ont commis
ces meurtres avant que les cadavres
commencent à s'empiler dit un des
meilleurs politique j'ai raconté je vais
te faire perdre ton hastings dans le
sport king
[Musique]
je veux devenir complètement débile 6
obtient des villes merde est ce que ça
va déchirer l'hymen
c'est le l'ecstasy purge suis pas
sniffer ça elle m
[Musique]
désolé pour la mort de ton amie humaine
celle epson eh ben tu devrais essayer
moi est ce que fait on des morts qui
sert une clio s que c'est ce que je
crois dire le bien
[Applaudissements]
et
ma tête oh ma tête
[Musique]